My name is David Robinson. I'm the council member
who's chairing this meeting. It's a Budget and Fiscal Affairs committee meeting.
It is Thursday, May 19, 2022, and it
is just past 09:00. A.m. Nine three and I call this meeting
to order and would like to welcome all council members and staff
who are here in attendance, and we will recognize
them very shortly. But first, I wanted to mention that this budget
workshop procedures will follow.
All budget workshops will be conducted in person, and our public
speakers have the option to comment in person or virtually 48
hours prior to the start of a workshop. All presentation materials
are uploaded to SharePoint and hard copies delivered to
each council office. All departments have been directed to provide
written responses within 48 hours of the conclusion of
their presentation to any questions posted by council members
to SharePoint the budget workshop schedule is
posted on the BFA website. Questions from council members
can be uploaded at any time during the budget workshop process,
the earlier the better, but allowing all the departments plenty of
time to respond to those questions.
All public speakers should be signed in to speak. If you have not signed
up, please sign in at the front table. My staff
here today includes staff from our Mayor Pro TEM
with Chief of Staff Jessica Beamer, as well as
Carolina here, who will be monitoring the Speaker's
list for the fiscal year 2023
budget amendment. Their template has been uploaded and
is available for council members on the SharePoint Budget
Workspace. And Mayor Turner has sent out a memo to
all council members and council offices to ensure productive
discussions on the fiscal year 2023 proposed
budget only operation, budget related amendments will be
considered. Policy amendments should not be submitted and will
be ruled out of order. And please see the Mayor's
memo for additional guidelines. Amendments are
due on Wednesday, May 25, at the end of Business.
And today on our agenda, we will hear from the
Controller with a special BFA Trends
report. We'll hear also from the Controller's office.
We'll hear from the Mayor's office, from Legal,
from Planning, from City Council and
our office collectively, as well as the
Administrative and Regulatory Affairs Group and Municipal
courts. Today is our final day of the budget workshops.
And as a reminder, these virtual meeting rules, the only
people attending virtually are public speakers.
We have seven virtual public speakers signed up for public comment
to speak after the Houston the
Municipal Courts presentation, and there are two in person
speakers that will begin after the virtual public speakers.
We'll get to the questions after the presentation and questions from council members
have concluded. Let me take a moment to recognize my colleagues
who are in the chamber. That's Dr. Carolyn Evans
Shabbaz of district D, the district of destination,
as well as council member Amy Peck from district A.
We have staff members represented from
District C, from District G,
from district H. We have representatives from the Vice
Mayor Pro Tems office in District K from District
F on the West Side, as well as the at large positions
four and five and representing
the AtLarge Two office. I too am here and with that Controller,
it's great to see you this morning. Welcome to the Chamber and sir, the floor
is yours. Thank you. Council members and
staff, I'm pleased to present the Trends Report for the fiscal year ending 2023.
At the time of this report, the economy is showing hopeful progress
in the recovery from COVID-19 Pandemic.
The infusion of more than 5 trillion in federal stimulus nationwide
has contributed to the generous robust sales tax receipt seen
since the passage of COVID relief legislation
in Houston. The receipt of more than 1 billion in response and recovery funding has
buoyed the otherwise bleak fiscal outlook seen pre pandemic.
We project the increases seen in several revenue sources,
namely sales tax, to be temporary. The FY
23 proposed budget uses 160,000,000 in
American Rescue Plan funding to address a habitual budget
deficit. This deficit would have required drastic
expenditure reductions citywide absent the receipt of federal
recovery funding. So this structural deficit existed
before COVID and will exist after ARPA funds are expended.
The decisions we make after and during this fiscal
year, while we have the benefit of the federal dollars,
will determine the size of that deficit in the future. The more than
606,000,000 made available through ARPA funding
provides the City with a golden opportunity to make tangible progress
towards reducing the structural deficit. The Controller's
Office encourages the Administration and Council to address
the City's long term financial liabilities with these funds and avoid
adding large recurring expenditures for which city leadership will have little means
to pay in the future. With that, I'm pleased to present the trends report
for FY 23. Next slide.
We'll move on to the next slide.
This is just a graph summary of all the different financials
and on this slide, General Fund revenues. It shows the Controller's
Office General Fund FY 22 projections,
our FY 23 Trends projections and the historical
information back to FY 18. Next slide.
In the General Fund revenues, the Controller's
Office is projecting an increase in our General Fund revenue projection by
15.8 million, or 0.6
tenths of a percent from our March FY 22 Mofar
projection. The major drivers of our projected increases
are property tax and intergovernmental revenues.
This amount includes the ARPA funds and we've seen
strong sales tax numbers month over month. But we believe
this is the temporary cumulative result of
a low interest rate environment, business continuing to return
to post COVID routines, and lastly,
the infusion of more than 5 trillion in federal stimulus
into the national economy. Next slide.
Property tax revenue. The property tax revenue for FY 23
is expected to be 3.97% higher than FY 22.
This amount could be higher as terse payments have yet to be paid out.
Property tax revenue continues to be an area of interest for our office as
we monitor the effects of Senate Bill Two and Proposition One revenue cap.
The city is still subject to the provisions of Senate Bill Two and we believe
the variable in Prop One's methodology, the Growth Index,
has the potential to trigger SB Two for the first time. So,
as of today, both prop One and SB Two apply to the city. But Prop
One has been far more restrictive over time and that might
change. Next slide the
Taxable Values based on a preliminary expected taxable
value from the three appraisal districts, the Controller's office projects
a 9.42% increase in taxable values.
The final taxable values are subject to change and will be finalized when the
certified roles are provided to the City.
Next slide taxable
value by Type residential properties make
up 53.4% of taxable values and
commercial properties make up 43.8%.
Collectively, the two property types make up 97.2%
of taxable values and as you can see,
residential and commercial values last were even in
FY 16. Since then we've seen the disparity between
the two widen and we believe this is a result of the more aggressive appraisal
protests by commercial property owners and also
the significant residential development.
Next slide sales
Tax FY 23 sales tax revenue is projected to increase
by 4.76% from our forecast FY
22 sales tax projection. This decrease
is an anticipated result of the effect of federal stimulus
tapering off.
Next slide the
Property Tax Rate this chart shows historical property tax rates.
The FY 23 rate is the same as the FY 22s
rate but will be updated once the Prop One calculation is finalized
and when the appraisal district certified roles are made available.
It is worth noting that FY 17 was the first year the city
had to decrease its tax rate to maintain compliance with Prop One.
Next slide total
Franchise Revenue total franchise revenue is projected decreased
by 2.2% from FY 22.
Total franchise revenue has been trending down in recent years.
We believe it's a cumulative result of SB 1152
and that's related to the telecom industries statewide
as well as consumers moving away from landlines and
cutting the cord I e. Digital streaming instead
of cable and satellite. Next slide
municipal Court Revenue municipal courts fines and forfeits are expected to
decrease by 6% for FY 23 based on an expected decrease
in collections, moving violations fees and court operations
revenue. We've seen municipal courts continue to trend down over the years
and obviously COVID had a pretty outsized effect on those revenues.
Next slide General Fund Expenditure
Budget the FY 23 General Fund total expenditure budget
is expected to increase by 3.8% over FY 22 projected
expenditures. That's an increase of 101.7 million.
The use of ARPA funds is the equivalent to which use
of non recurring revenue source that adds pressure to the city's structurally imbalanced
budget. ARPA funds must be leveraged to address the city's
structural deficit and some of its long term liabilities.
Instead, we're adding recurring costs for which we
don't have recurring revenue to match beyond and into
the future. So these recurring costs will
exacerbate an already stressed,
structurally imbalanced budget.
Next slide. Here you can just
see the general fund by percentage and function.
Public safety, as you all know, is a lion's share of the budget as
a percentage. And you can see the other breakdowns.
Next slide. The cash
versus fund balance. The unassigned fund balance is expected
to increase by 18.8 million in FY 22 and
decrease by 58.8 million in FY 23.
And the projected unassigned fund balance for fiscal
year 2022 is 300 million and for 2023
is 241,000,000. Next slide,
the seven and a half percent fund balance requirement. The FY
projected ending fund balance is expected to be 68 million above
the required seven and a half percent less debt service and
PAYGO. This represents a fund balance of
10.4% above the required seven and a half percent.
This is primarily a result of the one time financing sources
offered through American Rescue Plan and the 606,000,000
in funding. But the good news is we do have a pretty substantial
fund balance at this point in time.
Moving on, page 16. Next slide
houston Airport system has
revenue was significantly impacted by the Pandemic,
but our projections for FY 23 demonstrate a rebound as more people
begin to travel by air again, as borders open and foreign
countries relax COVID regulations, we'll continue to see more international routes come
back online. We have yet to see international passenger
numbers return to pre Pandemic levels and ARPA funds
are considered grant dollars and are not included in these revenue projections.
Next slide,
aviation revenues. The COVID-19 impact on airline travel
has resulted in 370,000,000,000 lost in airline revenue worldwide
and at one point air traffic was down nearly 70%.
So you can see the impact that it's had. But again, things are
starting to rebound with the exception of the international and some
of the business travel. Next slide.
Aviation expenses. Expenditures are up primarily due to
personnel expenditures increasing by 6.3 million or 5.5%
from FY 22. I would caution Council
on this that we need to be vigilant about this very item
expenditures in his going forward, especially if
we do not see that air traffic, both business and
international travel, returning to pre Pandemic
levels and again continue at a growth rate that's consistent
historically. Other services and charges are up by 4%
due to contractual services and interfund police and fire services.
Next slide convention
entertainment revenue and expenses. We anticipate CNE
will continue to see an upward trend in the recovery from the Pandemic. In FY
23, revenues are expected to increase by
20.6% or 17.4 million, for a total
of 102,000,000. Expenditures are expected
to increase by 18.6%, or 17.5 million,
for a total of 111.9 million.
The FY 23 deficit of 9.9 million ultimately
will result in a decrease in the ending total net position, so they will
draw that from fund balance. But the hope is that in the future things
continue. I know Council member, you've been involved there
and seen the struggle that they've been dealing with, but we're hopeful that things return
and they can build up fund balance in the future with future revenue.
Next slide convention and
entertainment revenues. As you know,
CNE was significantly impacted. Large gatherings
and events were canceled due to COVID.
So the primary CNE revenue is hotel occupancy
tax, which is reported as non operating revenue.
Hotel tax collections are projected to increase by 15.8
million, or 20.5% when compared to FY 22,
and this shows that travelers are largely returning to pre
pandemic routines. CNE is also seeing a projected
increase in operating revenues by 22.5%, or 1.7
million. That's due to increases in parking revenue
as a result of downtown area workers and commuters returning to pre
pandemic routines. Next slide,
CNE expenses. The CNE is projecting an increase of 18.6
or 17.5 million in expenses when compared to FY 22.
This increase is primarily a result of increased debt service payments,
an increase in transfer to component units, namely a transfer of 10
million to Houston first to address their deficit.
Next slide the combined utility System
Revenue and expenses. US expenditures are
projected to exceed revenues by 50.2 million in FY 23,
and that's primarily as a result of increased investment in sewer and
wastewater systems. And that's what's legally obligated as
part of the EPA's consent decree. As you
recall, this agreement Stipulates 2 billion investment must be made in the next
ten years. Our office is noting an increase in personnel cost,
salary cost, as well as nearly 1.2 in performance based bonus for
FY 23. So again, as we continue
to see this recovery, we need to make sure, not just in our general fund,
but also in our enterprise funds, that we are managing our expenses.
Next slide combined
Utility System Revenue The C US total revenue is expected to increase
by 92.6 million, primarily due to increased water and
sewer sales. However, these increases are offset by
decreases in projected sales of scraps and other revenue and impact fees.
Next Slide c
us expenditures. C US total expenditures are
expected to increase by 328.1 million and that's
due to debt transfer to capital projects and maintenance
costs. Changes in operating and maintenance expenses
reflect increases in personnel expenses, largely due to
pay for the increase in FTE headcount by 123
in FY 23.
Next slide.
I think that's the end of the presentation, so happy to answer
any questions. Thank you very much, Controller. I appreciate that and
a number of very helpful observations.
And while I might have a question or two, I wonder if there
are any from the array of council members
assembled, we do have four
virtual we think there are two virtual
public attendees online, and we may start with those.
But before going to that, I want to point out that your
points about the airport system and Houston first are particularly
helpful, I think today for some of those extracurricular
things that we really haven't seen too much of here. We did
have a good report from the director of the airport system yesterday with
his budget and there was some narrative and discussion about
the surrounding overall capital campaigns
investment that they're putting into the new facility. So appreciate your reminders
on that. So with that, I believe we will go to the public speakers
and we'll call first Miss Saba Blanding.
Ms. Blanding, if you're there, please unmute by hitting star
six. I think we see. I believe I'm unmuted.
Can you all hear me? Yes. Good morning, Ms. Blanding. Oh,
wonderful morning. How are you all doing today? Doing well,
thank you. And I apologize. I was trying to
finish a walk before you got to us, but you're like on top of it
today, so I'm outside. Yeah, and it's
a little hard to hear you, so if you can speak slowly
and clearly, that would be very helpful.
Absolutely. So I just wanted to take advantage of this new
format and give you all a chance to brag on yourselves and ask what
is the one thing you're most proud of Houston accomplishing in 2021?
And especially for district council members,
I'm just curious, especially for your district, specifically, what you're most proud
of? Well, thank you for that nice
question this morning from the Garden. I think I heard you say.
I don't see any district council members jumping
to respond. I know my big district.
It's the at large city. Very proud
of the diversity of our eleven distinct districts and
the incredible nature of our communities and
overlapping neighborhoods. Just makes me proud to be
a part of everything going on in the city right now. Ms.
Planning. How about you? What are you proud of?
Me? Yeah.
I really appreciated council member Plumber at
her amendment adding the additional two MCOT teams.
So anything we can do to invest in more
preventative direct mental health care is always a
win on my part. And I'm also loving the bike lanes you all
are doing and always the Bayou expansion is amazing.
It's a long list, so those are a top three, top of
mind. Well, very good. Thank you very much for being here today and
for your ongoing attendance here. Our next
speaker is Mr. Jason Oliver joining us
virtually. Mr. Oliver, if you can hit star six or
speak now.
Calling Jason Oliver. If you can unmute and
join us online.
Good morning. Thank you.
I'm thinking about this presentation and I'm wondering,
so the structural deficit is of course, something that
comes up every year.
If we get rid of the revenue cap,
I think that's around 280 or so million.
I'm wondering, will that kind of get us to
a place of being able to fully
fund some of these departments that we see are struggling, right?
If we do, will that address some of the needs that we've seen over
the past few days? And then also in terms of ARPA
funds, where are you seeing some strong opportunities and
candidates for investment that we may or may not be doing?
I'm trying to figure out are we making those structural investments? Thank you.
Thank you, Mr. Oliver, for the question. The controller may have something
he'd like to say. Here he is. Sure. Thank you for the question. The first
part being able to repeal
and again, I believe that would have to be through a voter referendum,
the property revenue cap,
prop One, rev cap that would go a long way towards
eliminating the structural budget imbalance based on
the current numbers. The challenge is we also have SB Two,
the statewide rollback rate cap that
we'd have to contend with. So it
might not be as effective as possible. But I know that there has
been discussion about that. One of the things that I've
suggested in the past, having been here now for 19
years and remembering Mayor Bill White, he passed
an amendment to lift the revenue cap for a specific purpose,
primarily for public safety. And he was able to,
again, through referendum, raise a $90 million cap for
public safety. That could possibly be an interim
step. And I know the administration has tossed that around in the past.
To the second question, the structural budget imbalances
existed before this administration, even as far back before the White
administration, during the Brown administration. So the
challenge is it keeps growing every year. And unfortunately,
this particular year, because of all the federal money,
it's going to grow substantially more, and that is
only cumulative into the future. One of the things
I've kind of said ad nauseam is the PFM report that the
administration and council, you know, approved and and authored
back in 2017. There are, you know, over 50
different items on there. And one of the things, in talking to the
various consultant groups that we interact
with, they said, this is a great plan, but you need someone to
go out and implement it. And specifically in the consulting world,
what they call PMO program management offices. And it takes
dollars to implement a lot of these things. Well, we have wonderful
employees at the city. We've been stretched thin. People are doing more
with less. So to answer your question,
one of my suggestions would be to take some of these federal dollars,
invest them to implement program management offices,
essentially consulting groups to go in and to implement
these PFM recommendations. Because as you all recall,
the cumulative effect of increased revenue and
reduction in expenses per the report was
around $300 million. So there's, I think, a lot of opportunities
to spend this money in a way that it doesn't create a recurring
expenditure in the future, but spend it to actually reduce
those or create new revenue.
Thank you very much, Controller. I think that's a very helpful
response to Mr. Oliver. Thank you for your question, sir.
And I do see one council
member in the queue just now. Council Member Alcorn. Go ahead. Thank you, Chair.
And thank you, Controller. I'm sorry I walked in a little bit late and
maybe you talked a little bit about since it's a trends report,
the trend of inflation and the trend of higher interest rates.
How do you see that playing out in revenues and
expenditures? So it is a challenge. We are in
a very inflationary period. We are seeing inflation
numbers that haven't been recorded since the
1980s. It's a challenge for the city in the sense
the cost of goods, of everything we purchase are going up.
Really to add on to that,
interest rates are rising. So the cost of debt service and issuance,
so these are putting financial strains on the budget.
The good news right now is we do have a lot of federal money.
Sales taxes up, property taxes up. But one of the things that
I've termed, and I'm going to date myself, when I started working in
an investment bank, alan Greenspan was the Federal Reserve Chair
and towards the end of the.com
boom he coined a term irrational
exuberance because stocks are rising, money was
coming in. I've said I think right now
and again, I've been here 19 years, I've been through the.com I'm
30 years almost in financial markets.
It seems to me a little bit like irrational exuberance. We're seeing sales
tax receipts over 20% on average. I mean, this is great news.
But the key for governments is it has to be sustainable.
And so the combined factor of
increased inflation, increases in interest rates that are going to hit debt service
and then this kind of false sense of security on revenues.
I'm, as I said, more cautionary going forward. And for
this fiscal year things are good and probably
next fiscal year, but when we run out of the federal ARPA
money, when that's limited? In December of 2024.
Really what's going to supplant that and you've talked about it in the past.
The key is matching recurring expenditures with recurring revenues so
we can't have a one time financing source with recurring expenditure.
Thank you, council member. And your response,
Controller. Go ahead.
Sure. Just one more question about the recent
changes to the OPEB,
to our retiree benefits which will bring down our
long term liability. Are you still in favor of
looking into an OPEB trust as well?
Yes. And I am. And this is a great example. In one of the things
that's mentioned in the PFM report, if we
set up an OPEB trust, essentially we are able to
not just do PAYGO for these retiree healthcare benefits,
we would actually invest that similar to the way we do in the pension.
We would earn a return on that money. The challenge in starting the
OPEB Trust is that we've never had the money to be able to fund
it initially. And now we're sitting on this huge amount of federal money.
What we can accomplish by putting 30, maybe $40
million into seat and OPEB Trust is,
first and foremost, we can secure health care benefits for retirees, because as
you all know around this table, those are not protected by state
law. We could vote as a council body tomorrow and eliminate all
of the retiree health care benefits. But more importantly,
we can use a higher discount rate when we are evaluating that unfunded
liability. So by putting a $30 million seed and
starting an OPEB Trust, we could significantly reduce
the long term unfunded liability of the OPEB,
and we could do similar to what we did with the pensions. We had an
$8 billion unfunded liability and now closer to 1.5
billion. Even with the reforms that Council passed previously
on OPEB, we're still going to see probably in the next 15 years,
4 billion or three plus billion dollar
unfunded liability. This OPEB Trust spending, that amount of money
would go a long way to reducing that long term unfunded liability.
Thank you, Controller. That'd be a great start. Appreciate the question.
Council Member Alcorn. We're going to hear from staff from Council Member Huffman's office.
Hi, Controller. I have two questions about the PFM report that you brought up.
One, given it happened in 2017, even though we paid like $500
million for it, do you think given all those
changes since then, those recommendations are still relevant today,
and then two, in your opinion, could ARPA
dollars be not certainly better spent, but spent
on implementing some of those cost savings that the PFM report
recommends? Yeah, so good question.
I think around $580,000 that we spent
on the report. Absolutely.
To the extent the ARPA money is fungible and we
can use some of that for implementing these ideas,
I would think there would probably need to be a refresher
in the sense that yes, it has been five years.
But I think the good news is, based on inflation and some
of these other things, there might actually be more opportunity to
save money today than in the past.
But I think that the challenge is identifying
the right teams to be able to go out and do this, that have experience
doing it in other cities and can do it in a cost
effective manner. Because one of the things I have seen historically
at the city is we've spent money on projects like this
and we spent a lot of money on them, and they haven't utilized the
results. So I think it's important who
you'd select. But I think absolutely, I think that was kind of the point I
made earlier. We need to be using these federal dollars to
reduce the structural imbalance in the future by adding
more revenue or reducing recurring expenditures, rather than
adding recurring expenditures.
Thank you for that response and that gets to the end
of our questions from the Horseshoe.
And I just wanted to get one further bit of commentary
from you. You quoted Greenspan with the irrational exuberance
of times past. And in
one of your charts for the sales tax revenue you spoke about the tapering off
effect of some of the stimulus and curious
about that, having heard recently the state's comptroller,
Mr. Hager, talk about where we are with
some of the incredible returns that we were getting through last year.
Just in your opinion,
is that part of the irrational exuberance or is that
what's about to taper off? Well, I think it's to this point
the irrational exuberance I think we're seeing yesterday in the stock market,
for example, we're down 1100 points on the Dow. I mean, I think inflation,
all these things really it's the multi trillion dollars
of money that's been pumped into the economy that's just pushed everything up.
It's pushed the stock market up. The rates of interest rates being
lowered have done that as well. But definitely, I think from
us. I can't remember a time at the city where we had
an eight month rolling average of over 20% in
sales tax. Now you have to couch that historically
because COVID it was down quite a bit. But even with COVID being down,
the rebound is spectacular. So just
a principle for governmental budgeting. You really
just plan on having a 3% to 5% increase
hopefully every year and you base it off that. And if you go way below
that or you go way above that, that delta starts to get very difficult
to manage. So I think we were down and now we're
so high up, I just caution the body that it's not going
to sustain itself. And yes, we do expect sales tax to normalize
next year and even be down year over year. But again,
that's because we're up probably in the year, up 20% this year.
And these are good things. It's just you have to prepare when you have
very volatile times. You have to make kind of more long term strategic
decisions in the sense that it's not going to go up another three or 5%
probably next year. It's definitely not going to go up 20% again
next year. I appreciate that very much. Thanks for
that final comment. And I think this does conclude our special called
BFA committee meeting. So. Thank you,